We will now work with a
geometric random variable and
put to use our understanding
of conditional PMFs and
conditional expectations.
Remember that a geometric random
variable corresponds to
the number of independent
coin tosses until
the first head occurs.
And here p is a parameter
that describes the coin.
It is the probability of heads
at each coin toss.
We have already seen the formula
for the geometric PMF
and the corresponding plot.
We will now add one very
important property which is
usually called Memorylessness.
Ultimately, this property has
to do with the fact that
independent coin tosses do
not have any memory.
Past coin tosses do not affect
future coin tosses.
So consider a coin-tossing
experiment with independent
tosses and let X be the
number of tosses
until the first heads.
And X is a geometric
with parameter p.
Suppose that you show up a
little after the experiment
has started.
And you're told that there was
so far just one coin toss.
And that this coin toss
resulted in tails.
Now you have to take over and
carry out the remaining tosses
until heads are observed.
What should your model
be about the future?
Well, you will be making
independent coin tosses until
the first heads.
So the number of such tosses
will be a random variable,
which is geometric
with parameter p.
So this duration--
as far as you are concerned--
is geometric with parameter p.
Therefore, the number of
remaining coin tosses starting
from here--
given that the first
toss was tails--
has the same geometric
distribution as the original
random variable X.
This is the Memorylessness
property.
Now, since X is the total number
of coin tosses and
since your coin tosses were
all of them except for the
first one, the random variable
that you are concerned
with is X minus 1.
And so the geometric
distribution that you are
seeing here is the conditional
distribution of X minus 1
given that the first toss
resulted in tails, which is
the same as the event that X
is strictly larger than 1.
So the statement that we have
been making is the following
in more mathematical
language--
that conditioned on X being
larger than 1, the random
variable X minus 1, which is the
remaining number of coin
tosses, has a geometric
distribution with parameter p.
Let us now give a more precise,
mathematical argument.
But first, for a special case.
Let's us look at the conditional
probabilities for
the random variable X minus 1.
And calculate, for example, the
conditional probability
that X minus 1 is equal to 3,
given that X is larger than 1.
Which is the same as saying
that the first
toss resulted in tails.
Now, the first toss
resulted in tails.
This is the probability that
you will need three more
tosses until you
observe heads.
Needing three more tosses until
you observe heads is the
event that you had tails in the
second toss, tails in the
third toss, and heads
in the fourth toss.
And all that is conditioned
on the first toss
having resulted in tails.
However, the different coin
tosses are independent.
So the conditional
probabilities, given the event
that the first toss was tails
should be the same as the
unconditional probabilities.
The first toss does not change
our beliefs about the
probabilities associated with
the remaining tosses.
Now, this unconditional
probability is easy to calculate.
It is 1 minus p squared--
because we have two
tails in a row--
times p.
Now, we observe that this
quantity here is the
probability that a geometric
random variable takes the
value of three.
Here what have we calculated?
We have calculated the PMF of
the random variable X minus 1
in a conditional universe where
X is larger than 1.
And we evaluated it
for a value of 3.
The probability that our random
variable X minus 1
takes the value of 3.
So what we have shown is that
this conditional PMF is the
same as the unconditional PMF.
Now, there is nothing special
about the number 3.
You can generalize this argument
and establish that
the conditional probability of
X minus 1 given that X is
strictly larger than one, for
any particular k, is the same
as the corresponding probability
for the random
variable X, which is given
by the geometric PMF.
Finally, there is nothing
special about the value of 1
that we're using here.
In fact, we can generalize
and argue as follows--
suppose that I tell you that X
is strictly larger than n.
That is, the first n tosses
resulted in tails.
Once more, these past tosses
were wasted but have no effect
on the future.
So the conditional PMF of the
remaining number of tosses
should be, again, the same.
Therefore, the statement we're
making is that this geometric
PMF will also be the PMF of
X minus n, given that X is
strictly larger than n, and this
will be true no matter
what argument we plug-in
into the PMF.
We will now exploit the
Memorylessness property of the
geometric PMF and use it
together with the total
expectation theorem to
calculate the mean or
expectation of the
geometric PMF.
If we wanted to calculate the
expected value of the
geometric using the definition
of the expectation, we would
have to calculate this infinite
sum here, which is
quite difficult.
Instead, we're going to
use a certain trick.
The trick is the following--
to break down the expected value
calculation into two
different scenarios.
Under one scenario we obtain
heads in the first toss.
And in that case the
random variable X--
the number of tosses until
the first heads--
is equal to 1.
And this scenario occurs
with probability p.
And we have another scenario
with probability 1 minus p
where we obtain tails
in the first toss.
And in that case, our
random variable is
strictly larger than 1.
Now, the expected value of
X consists of two pieces.
We have a first toss
no matter what.
And then we have the number
of remaining tosses,
which is X minus 1.
So this is true by linearity
of expectations.
Now, the expected value of X
minus 1 consists of two pieces
using the total expectation
theorem.
The probability of the first
scenario times the expected
value of X minus 1 given
that X is equal to 1,
plus 1 minus p--
the probability of the
second scenario--
times the expected value of
X minus 1 given that X
is bigger than 1.
Now, this term here is 0.
Why?
If I tell you that X is equal
to 1, then you're certain
that's X minus 1
is equal to 0.
So this term gives
a 0 contribution.
How about the next term?
We have a 1 minus p here times
this expected value.
Now this random variable,
conditioned on this event, has
the same distribution as an
ordinary, unconditioned
geometric random variable.
So this expectation here must be
the same as the expectation
of an ordinary, unconditioned,
geometric random variable.
And this gives us an equality.
Both sides involve the expected
value of X. But we
can solve this equation for
the expected value.
And we obtain the end result
that the expected
value is 1 over p.
By the way, this answer
makes intuitive sense.
If p is small, this means
that the odds of
seeing heads is small.
Then in that case, we need to
wait longer and longer until
we see heads for
the first time.
Setting aside the specific form
of the answer that we
found, what we have just done
actually illustrates that
fairly difficult calculations
can become very simple if one
breaks down a model or a problem
in a clever way.
This is going to be a recurring
theme throughout
this class.